oh hi it's been four years and I still
don't know how to introduce myself on a
vlog but hello how's it going I'm here
because I want to say words and words is
the only thing that I have to do good
apparently not god damn it okay so I
wanted to make a video because I want to
talk to you guys about some thoughts
that I've been having about YouTube
because just a few days ago it was
actually the four year anniversary that
I've been on YouTube it's four years ago
that I started posting videos and four
years ago that my life totally changed
and became all about YouTube and the
only thing that I have the right to talk
about is things that are in my immediate
bubble and my bubble is very small but
my bubble involves YouTube I don't want
to talk about international politics or
like that but I do know YouTube
because I live YouTube I experience
YouTube every day I wake up and think
about YouTube I wake up and think about
the videos that I was supposed to make
the day before but I was too lazy to
make and then I got to make them that
day and then I got to hurry up and get
ahead of my schedule
I know YouTube and I love doing YouTube
I love making videos for you guys it's
it's literally the purpose that I've put
my life to and that is good because it
gives me something that I am motivated
for it gives me something that pushes me
forward and higher and makes me a better
person and also it puts food on the
table so that I'm not starving so this
all combines into something that is very
important to me YouTube is my life
YouTube is everything that I do it's
literally the only priority that I have
in my daily life and that's because I
love doing it and I love doing it and
then that makes me self reflect on what
YouTube is turning into and YouTube is
changing YouTube has changed over the
years many times it's changed
leadership's it's changed design
decisions sorry new people have come in
old people have left people have moved
around you guys have changed your tastes
but what I see
doing this for four years is what I can
only describe and I took a lot of time
thinking about these words is a
self-fulfilling cycle of pessimism and
that's a big phrase for marking Buddha
say but that is the only way that I can
describe what I see every day and what I
mean by self-fulfilling self so for
today even think I don't even know what
I say by the vicious cycle of pessimism
is what I'm gonna call it now someone
caught me on that is that when people
are doing YouTube they are after a few
things and you can't fault them for it
because of course people would want to
do this for the living but they're after
influence more viewers and money and
that's fine you know you I am I would be
a hypocrite if I said I would do this
for free because I couldn't and I
wouldn't because it's part of my income
and it's how I live so of course I want
to do it it's my job but I don't treat
it as my job but it is my job so I'm
hypocritical if I was to criticize
anyone for going after YouTube for money
and that's not what I'm doing
because even YouTube the business if you
asked an executive at YouTube they would
go we want more views more money more ad
revenue and more more more more MORE and
you can't exactly fault them for that is
the nature of the business of things but
what I know being at the heart of
YouTube and being where I am now from
where I started I've seen this change in
attitude and it's very subtle and it's
hard to see but it's definitely there
it's a change from seeing YouTube as a
platform where anyone can do anything
and anyone can put up whatever they want
whenever they want to a system where you
have to follow strict rules you have to
follow strict protocols you have to
criticize others it's every man for
himself and no one can cooperate and I'm
not saying it's bombastic that's what it
is but that's what it's starting to be
because as more and more people try to
flood in the system the more and more
people try to hold
type under what they have and they don't
want to let go and I can't fault them
for that easier like like they worked
hard to make their YouTube channels and
they worked hard to make something and
so they they want to attack others and
they want to cause drama and they want
to make things happen and I'm not naming
names here there's a general sense I am
never gonna name names on this I have
way too much respect for too many people
to start calling people out and doing
exactly what I'm saying is happening but
it is happening and it's a
self-fulfilling cycle of pessimism
because people want more and then more
people want more and then the people
want other people to have less because
they want more and then more people want
more and then more people want others to
have less and it's becoming less of a
community about making cool videos for
you guys which is what it always has
been about it always should be about it
should be about you guys and you guys
alone and you guys actually have the
power in this system because it's a
weird democratic process if you guys
watch a video obviously there's a demand
for that video people are gonna make
more of that type of video and you guys
get what you want if you guys don't
watch a video then obviously that video
isn't going to do as well and not as
many people are gonna want to make that
type of video and that's fine that's how
it works that's how you guys have the
power and that's got how you guys shape
what YouTube is the only thing that I
have wrong with it is that it stifles
creativity for the sake of creativity
and I'm like I'm guilty in this too
because I do the same thing like I make
videos because people want to see them
and and I do that and so that is the
thought that I had recently was why do I
do this I do it because I love it right
that should be the answer like I do yes
of course and it is the answer but at
the same time I felt like this pang of
shame
you know this sense in my mind that I
was almost ashamed of what it's become
and I'm not but I felt it and it dawned
on me
that I had more fun making a video where
I stared at a banana for five minutes
and then 1.7 million people watched it
by the way I didn't make those subtitles
of the subtitles are open to you guys
you guys make the fun you guys made you
guys made that better you've been made
it better from the subtitles that was so
cool and so fun and that's what I love
about YouTube like you can put up
anything anyone can put up anything and
that's great and that's wonderful anyone
can put up absolutely anything but
that's happening less and less on my
part too like I said I'm guilty I'm
hypocritical for criticizing anyone for
doing this because I'm guilty too I've
made videos you know just because people
want to see more of them and there's
nothing wrong with that but it's leading
down to a road where that's all that's
ever gonna happen instead of trying to
surprise you guys with new and
interesting things and sometimes very
stupid things like me staring at a
banana for five minutes or eating a bowl
of cereal for five minutes it's you know
it's moments like that that I look back
on my channel you know I don't look back
at like part 13 of a let's play that I
did three years ago I look back at the
fall of Slenderman I look back at like a
jump-scare friends I look back at Marga
pliers magic touch I look back at those
you know I think about the impossible
Let's Plays the the weird things that
I've done the the April Fool's jokes
that I've done I think back to those I
love those those are cherished memories
in my heart and they're always gonna be
there always and that's what I want to
see more out of YouTube and that's what
we're not seeing more out of YouTube I
mean I'm just saying it's not happening
it's definitely happening but in smaller
and smaller quantities as years go by
so if if you guys are looking for a
point of this video I don't even know if
I could wrap it up in one sentence but
the point that I'm trying to make or
that at least I will try to halfway get
to making is that YouTube is changing
into a system that is only rewarding for
more views and more money and it's been
that way for a long time and me it's
easy for me to say it's not a good thing
because I'm obviously sitting hi our
button on the youtubes rung and people
look to me for advice I'm like wow I
don't know what I'm doing why are you
talking to me and so like Who am I to
say what one thing is or another but
these are the observations that I make
and me being someone that loves to watch
youtube videos and loves to see these
cool things I don't want it to turn into
a constant money mill and I don't want
to make sure that it doesn't do that
either because I love making videos for
you guys I love making videos for you
guys I love it with all my heart I love
doing the weird things so much you guys
don't understand how much I love doing
these things and I care about it I care
about YouTube I care about what people
make on YouTube and it sickens me to see
some of the that comes out of
the stupid cycle of pessimism the ever
turning wheel of I'm better than you and
that sucks and I don't know how to fix
it
I really don't because I don't think I
can but I know that you guys can and I
know that you guys can because you guys
are the ones that are in control of
literally everything we are slaves see
you guys like we the YouTube creators we
are like indebted to you for everything
that we have and I always try to
maintain that sense of gratitude to you
guys because I am so grateful for what
you guys have done to change my life and
change the world in what we've done you
know and all the charity efforts but
expanding beyond just me
like you guys are in control of
everything and I love you guys for that
and I love what we do together and I
love everything about you too I just
don't want to see it go down a dark road
and again I'm not being apocalyptic I'm
not trying to fight the system
I'm just saying thoughts that I have had
given my expertise on YouTube so I don't
think I made a single point in this
entire video I think I just rambled for
way too long but those are my feelings
about what it means to make videos on
YouTube and what it means to owe
something to you guys and what it means
to do things for the sake of having fun
and make things because no one asked
them to be made no one wanted it to be
baked but it was made anyway and it was
wonderful and that's the beauty of what
YouTube is and hopefully will be so
anyway I'll stop rambling that's that's
pretty much all I wanted to say if if
anyone wants to try to stitch a coherent
paragraph out of everything but I just
rambled about feel free go to town on it
maybe I'll put it in the description but
you know just in the end thank you guys
for letting me be stupid in front of
millions of people so thanks again
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye